brother intro music Jake's not here to
play a guitar or banjo he hasn't busted
out his banjo in a long time so it's
just us chilling on the couch you got
Sam you got Fender you got Dean you got
me Nico welcome to the corridor cast our
anime rock paper scissors video just
dropped and that's what we're gonna be
talking about and we literally just
watched it well yeah actually so this
we're recording this on Wednesday uh the
week before and we all just watched it
for the very first time effectively it's
like this you know in the crew videos of
quarter Crew videos where we do like
little moment where we all react to our
stuff we just filmed that so we all just
are buzzing yeah after doing that like
buzzing and also completely exhausted
from all the work yeah all every laugh
every smile has been sucked out of me
gave it all to that video
it's really good though it turned out
well it's awesome people like it yeah
well at this point we don't know what
the reception's been like on YouTube oh
well let's predict people generally had
a good time
I'm predicting that people will
generally like it because yeah I think
Mike summary my consensus my takeaway
from the little viewing was uh yeah
there's AI Jank going on but generally
you kind of just like accept it and then
just start watching the piece and that
happens
I wonder though and this we'll see what
the reception of it is like for people
who come to that video with no knowledge
of the making of it
what they'll like what kind of feeling
the animation will give them yeah
because like if there's a little you
know Shadow lines or warbling and stuff
I wonder yeah I just wonder how that'll
land with people who have no idea that
there's like AI going on yeah I wonder
if we could not that we're trying to
fool people but like I wonder if anybody
will watch it and because actually we
saw some I saw some comments on the
spider-verse video where they're like oh
you guys must have taken months
animating this yeah and I think there
will genuinely be people watching be
like oh that's cool I think especially
because there's more like actual
Artistry with these shots like some of
Sam shots it's like full-on just like I
mean it is Anime it's like yeah we're
just skipping that one step about like
drawing the character like we're only a
few like Steps removed from like just
tracing the video by hand yeah and like
using a paint bucket and Photoshop to
fill it in well that's like the thing I
feel like most people are gonna see or
feel when they watch it for the first
time is like oh wait this is like one of
those things where they like draw over
the picture a little bit like it's like
a scanner darkly kind of thing yeah yeah
now I showed a friend a a test shot and
that was it was like oh did you guys
like Trace over it or something and I
was like no computer spit it out yeah
computer traced over and really yeah
that's what it's doing it's tracing over
it
you just gotta do everything else
afterwards and before yeah
man
when we started this we had no idea if
it worked though no it was just like ah
we'll start shooting it and we'll do
some of the shots and we'll see how they
turn out remember well this it started
way back I I you know we're putting
together the the crew video that goes in
depth on it
we have footage back from October from
like first working on it because there
was a week there was like it was like a
week or two weeks where you and I
literally just spent all day just like
yeah typing in stuff stairs right yeah
on the Matrix stuff yep it's like Matrix
working on them change the number hit go
change the number hit go just trying to
figure out what every single thing does
yeah and I think that was because
early on you were like we got to do this
uh kind of alternative process uh the
image damage all process which is you
know for the spider-verse video for
people don't know we were just using a
really basic like
uh you take an image
you run it through uh image to image
which basically lays a random noise
pattern over it and reinterprets the
image with some of the text prompts you
gave it and that worked pretty well for
that video because we were just locking
off the faces and and kind of focusing
on that but
you I think after seeing uh the Jurassic
Park low poly Jurassic Park person named
hops on YouTube yeah yeah which it was
it felt different than all the AI videos
that had come before which were just
like they just look kind of like some
kind of weird psychedelic dream yeah
there's no coherence to it but yeah his
stuff was using this alternative process
which uh you know to my understanding
literally takes the input image and then
puts it into latent space in a sense to
like derive a noise pattern yeah from
that it's basically like you know if
you're taking noise and turning into an
image you just literally do that
backwards just do this exact same math
formula but backwards so you take an
image and turn it into noise and you
just end up with an image where the
noise only changes if the image changes
it only changes in the parts of the
image where the parts of the image
changes so like it ends up locking it
down it needs to lock down and it lets
it move and parts that are naturally
moving
yeah and it like structurally kind of
matches the image too so it just kind of
takes its step of preserving all the
detail just making it a little bit
better but it's still flickery and I
remember so you were like testing that
stuff
and Fender and I were gonna do that
spider reverse video I was like I don't
it doesn't seem like it's going there
like there was it was lit I mean I think
at the end of the day it was literally
like a check box that you were like oh I
checked this off and then it works yeah
but that's kind and that's kind of how
it feels with a lot of this stuff is
like we're just moving around sliders
all day and then you know the initial
tests look like just garbled deep fried
weirdness with noise patterns and then
suddenly it pops into just being like a
perfect image and you're like oh write
those settings down
yeah
yeah and once that started happening
like
oh it's been it's been quite a journey
like getting from there to like a
functional piece because we did we did a
whole bunch of tests or it's just like
one of us you know being on a green
screen moving our face around and like
the real question was can you get an
Express expression to stick and like the
Arcane the Arcane cartoon show animation
style is like our first real foray into
trying to like do this we quickly like
realized that it'd just be weird to have
an Arcane styled piece yeah yeah like
and it's not Arcane and just like it's
directly being pulled from Arcane like
we should try to do something that's a
little more just like true anime or like
a little a little more obscure like
Vampire Hunter D let's find something
yeah it's a classic like Gothic it's a
classic Gothic anime Vibe you know and I
also feel like Arcane like being that
they're still even at the end of this
process there's still a little bit of
flickering there's still a little bit of
inconsistency
it doesn't work for CG you know
animation like mimicking a CG animation
because Arcane CG so like if there's
like weird little flickering going on it
really people it feels off but like if
you do hand-drawn animation inherently
if somebody's sitting there and drawing
every frame there's going to be
a slight difference in every frame so it
really maps on well to that yeah like I
wonder I wonder how much we should talk
about like the actual like diffusion
process in this podcast like how techy
we should get like there is there's a
decent breakdown in the behind the
scenes in the quarter crew you know
Channel
um but like it'd probably just be worth
touching upon it real quick so people
have an idea of like what's going on in
this and you know basically if you
imagine
you have an image sequence you know
basically a video
and you have an AI tool here that can
take a picture and kind of reimagine the
picture to look a little bit different
it's like well let's just run it on a
whole video and make a whole video look
like something different it'd be cool
and that's like that would be cool
except every image ends up being
interpreted differently due to the fact
that there's like a heavy random nature
to this because of like the whole way
it's using noise to generate the images
so it all just falls apart and like
there's nothing in built into this it's
you know it's just looking at visual
forms there's nothing built into this to
have a sense of like oh there was like a
window here earlier there should still
be a window here now on this picture of
a wall that I'm drawing it's like it
just it doesn't understand the world
like that it doesn't have any like this
process you know I feel like AI is a bit
of a misnomer now we all just say it
because it's like it was what was in
movies but it's like
it's not like this is really an
artificial intelligence it's an it's a
statistical
visual pattern yeah matching system you
know it's a machine learning process not
necessarily an artificial intelligence
um but it sounds clear to say AI so we
do
um but yeah so this this AI just ends up
giving you a bunch of random images that
look Loosely inspired by what you fed it
but we kind of discovered through a
bunch of trial and error that if you use
this process to get generate noise from
the image which in the automatic 1111
interface which is basically what we're
all using for this program it's the
image to image alternative script down
at the bottom and if you use that you
combine it with a dream boost model so a
custom tuned model like as you might
have seen in uh as we've done did
earlier last or later last year like the
medieval fantasy story you take one of
these Custom Dream boost models and you
train both like a style and it could be
any style of your choosing plus like a
subject if you then then take a picture
of like somebody on a green screen so
it's just the person no backgrounds and
it's that same person that's trained
into the model plus the style you can
actually end up getting and use the
whole image to image alternative thing
so you're using a more refined noise
process you end up getting something
that's very close to being consistent
but not quite almost consistent so then
if you take it into like any effects
program and basically apply like d
Flickr plugins and like noise removal
plugins and you know dirt removal
plugins it cleans it up and suddenly we
have like a frame a cartoon frame that's
consistent with the one ahead and the
one behind it or at least close enough
and like that's that's what we tried to
figure out for this process you know we
talk about like hey wouldn't it be cool
to see somebody use these tools
creatively to see them liberate artists
and like you know now anybody can make a
cartoon and then it's like yeah it would
be cool to see that so who's going to do
it
and it's like screw up we'll give it a
shot
bigger rock paper scissors anime I feel
like a lot of people in the AI space
are you know not in the VFX space or at
least the AI image Generation stuff it's
like everybody's attempting to just like
I want it to to get to a point where I
can hit a button and it looks like kind
of the results we're getting but um if
you just like a couple weeks yeah
especially after this video goes out
hopefully yeah but it's like if you just
put a little bit of effort on the back
end with post-processing
it gets so much closer yeah and um
that's what's really
exciting about it is like yeah we're
using it as a tool continually and we're
like showing how it can be continued to
be used as a tool to like again bring
the idea to the four and like execute on
the concept it's not like we're hitting
the button and the script for the videos
coming out or that the idea itself is
coming out it's like it's just a tool in
the process yeah I mean like in a
nutshell though it's it's a filter
basically yeah if you look at the whole
video everything else everything that
happened in this video is just like what
you do during a normal animation process
except there's a cool filter plug-in we
have that goes like Boop and makes the
photos look more cartoony yeah and then
all the other work still goes into it
yeah when we started like putting our
shots together because like first we'd
film ourselves on the green screen
posing and acting like anime characters
and then we'd you know edit that and we
run it through and you basically get it
traced into cartoon form and once you
popped off the green screen and put a
background there instead like the first
results were like oh this kind of really
looks like
somebody on a green screen with a
background replacement even though
there's this whole cartoon filter on it
it wasn't until like we started
animating things it's like okay let's
have the background move a little bit
let's have the person slide a little bit
let's add a visual cue A visual
representation of like anger or
something like that you know let's do a
color shift and a little vignette and
different lines over here it's like once
we put like the literally like the
animation touch into every shot then it
went from being oh this is a video to
this is an animation at least in my eyes
like it's I started feeling that Vibe of
watching you're watching
you know abstractions representing
something versus just an actual
photograph of something
yeah did you have like one specific
moment like your aha moment where you're
like okay this video is going to be
sweet I feel like that came in during
the tests that we were doing earlier was
just shots in the green screen yeah he
was like the first time
popped off popped out of a green popped
out a green screen the first time I
keyed a green screen and then like
dropped anime lines on a shot that I
also had D flickered and run through the
process yeah and like and you just see
it it's like this looks like a cartoon I
just made like a four second long shot
from a cartoon yeah it's crazy it
actually worked
yeah that was like some of the earlier
Arcane tests you know that we were doing
those were like showing a lot of
potential yeah and then just like
watching the whole program evolve
because it's like it's so open source so
many people are like I mean it's still
open source obviously like so many
people are actively contributing to it
that's just like it's moving so fast and
it's really cool to see that because
it's like
if the community's in charge of it you
know it's
like I worry I worry at some point that
like these tools get like like for
example like uh you know chat GPT and
then you have like Microsoft's what was
it called
um just being yeah being in there's like
Google's barred it's like so here's
somebody that's has like you know a
machine learning model that's been
trained on all this you know script and
text out there that everybody's just
collectively written on the internet you
know and they're going to use it for
their company to and what they're going
to change behind the scenes to be like
you know it's like here we're gonna make
it useful maybe not quite so useful
until we get you can either direct you
to here so somebody's paying us for ads
or here it's like I don't want them
manipulating it for their gain while I
use it I just I like I don't want to
compromise tool I want a tool it just
does what it's supposed to do like if
somebody's gonna make a helpful Search
Assistant I want to just be purely a
Search Assistant as best it can be I
don't want to be a Search Assistant that
is also scheming to like get me to like
pay money here or to like help these
people are paying for ads here like I
don't like that and and having something
like stable diffusion well stable
diffusion is a misnomarks that's like
the underlying function of like how this
diffusion process kind of works so it's
one of them and they also train models
but this automatic 11 11 program this
interface you know for this thing that
has so many features and scripts now
having it be Community Driven
effectively means like that every single
function here serves only one purpose
and the purpose is to be as good as it
can be at doing this I'm I'm so curious
to see the updates to automatic 1111
post the anime rock paper scissors video
because I feel like it'll just be like
hey there's a deflicker mode in batch
image damage now like yeah more creative
yeah or even just having batch image
damage create a folder automatically
rather than yeah it's funny because of
the file you can load your settings from
yeah everything yeah yeah like that yeah
having to like redo all your settings in
the prompts and or maybe don't vary the
most useful image to image feature in a
script called image to image alternative
test
yeah yeah all the way down like most of
the project
was like media management you know like
yeah it was kind of really just because
Da Vinci resolve which we're using to
edit is also there's some limitations in
terms of like exporting like you know
this this program only takes like PNG
sequences so there's just like it was
all the little resolved automatic eleven
eleven yeah yeah the result takes more
than PHP sequences
like in a specific page you know yeah so
it's like please make resolve export PNG
sequences thanks yeah from the deliver
page but um it was like
the whole process was just like okay
like export the media to this folder and
then bring that into this web UI browser
and then batch that out and then bring
that in as an image to update the
spreadsheet on Google Docs yeah like the
spreadsheets because yeah you film it
and get a file and then you chop it and
Export it and get an image sequence and
then you process that image sequence and
get another image sequence and then
sometimes for me I bring that into
fusion and then D Flicker and make
another a fourth version of that shot
with transparency and then sometimes I
would then upres it and make a fifth
image sequence on that same shot we
filmed so there's five versions of it
now yeah and then you take it to After
Effects and now I'm ready for After
Effects export that and then bring that
in and the tiny thing is that actually
one or three shots I bring it back into
fusion and do the keying there because
it's a little more effective than an
after effects and so yeah then I end up
with six versions of the file before I
do any like creative work on it which
and that's that's like a healthy chunk
of time just like waiting for things to
you know export and moving them around
and I feel like it's almost it makes the
instantaneousness of of the process a
little bit obscure because like really
if this if all of that was automated it
would be
20 seconds for each every frame oh yeah
like every shot ends up having at least
one to two hours of just management
associated with just that shot existing
yeah yeah and it like if it was all and
again like we talked about this will
probably be available in three weeks but
like if it was like whatever compositor
you're working in it is you just pipe
the media into a node that goes this is
your stable diffusion node and then you
do all your stable diffusion stuff and
pipe it out of there then that
instantaneousness is like it's it's all
right there you know and you're just
waiting for it to render so I I bet you
could get chat gpt3 to write that oh
geez yeah write the code yeah yeah
no it's like the really trippy thing
about this project was as we get going
into it realizing that every single shot
literally every single shot is a VFX
shot yeah there's no parts that are just
in an edit it's like every single shot
needs to be tagged named accounted for
put into a folder sent out round trip to
other things like there's not a single
shot that doesn't get packed up into
frames run through four other programs
and then brought back and like to do
that for a couple you know do that for
10 or 20 or 30 shots in a video
it's kind of a pain but you deal with it
right everything else just lives in the
timeline it's easy but with this video
it has to happen for every single shot
that was a totally new experience for me
at least yeah well I thought it was I
kind of enjoyed that first week
uh right so we did our first shoot so we
broke the shoot up and then like yeah
those like three days or so you know
filmed for a few hours for three days
and then um but that first week I
remember it was just like all right
everyone we're all doing the video right
now here's uh
the shots we filmed and go for it and
then it's like zero directions zero like
there's no like hey here's what we're
trying to do with any it's just like
here's a bunch of shots everyone just do
shots so we all did like three shots put
them together and it's just like you're
like okay here's all the different
approaches you could possibly take for
this video Yeah and everyone then we all
kind of just look at them all and then
just kind of averages out basically over
those first one or two weeks it's just
yeah and that first sequence is usual
yeah where we all just like all right
just do a shot yeah yeah it's like how
do you do an anime shot it's like figure
it out let's do it all together yeah
yeah because by the end there I felt
like it came together so quick like it
was like just the curve of like how we
actually got it done was crazy yeah the
speed by the end was it was it was also
a matter of like you know Nico you made
these models of you know basically we
were using two models for this video
which was like a stable diffusion model
that had included my likeness plus the
Vampire Hunter D style and then one
thing plus plus the data of you in the
vampire D style oh yeah that was the
humans that was the extra the exhaust on
top which is like that's a really
interesting step which clarified people
it's like we had a model of stable
diffusion that was trained on my
likeness and the Vampire Hunter D style
which is just a bunch of images from
that that film
and then we
took images of me and trained that we
trained that we got a dream Booth model
there yeah we got a dream Booth model
and then with that dream Booth model
generated images of me in the style so
basically the character that we were
going to have in the final piece put
those images back into the training set
ran it again a new Fresh model a new
Fresh model that had basically
it was as if we had an artist like look
at me and draw me in this style it's a
style sheet or whatever yeah the
characters yeah which is to me that was
the most
one of the more exciting pieces of it
because
you know if if you're gonna make
something like truly original because
this in a sense is kind of a parody of
of anime so it kind of makes sense to
draw an actual anime but like if you're
trying to make something truly original
with this approach that's the step where
you would bring in an artist to do the
purely creative work of like finding the
characters right yeah and then the
maybe more boring side of it which is
like drawing you know they don't have to
draw it every they don't have to draw
every frame of your movie yeah you just
have to draw the characters and design
them and like come up with the
environments and the vibe like it gives
you all the art stuff yeah and then they
also like okay can you do that can you
draw that picture person two thousand
more times please yeah yeah it's like
they'd have to do that part of it and
the way the tech is moving even if
people wanted to
you know because obviously there's
limitations of of using a real human as
a reference plate because we can't move
and we were finding that we were
actually having to contort ourselves a
little bit to like move like anime
characters but uh there's a world in
which uh you know there's some new stuff
coming out where you can take a line
drawing a scribble basically and use
that as a as a guide for the the output
of the character so you could literally
just draw a janky sketch kind of
animation and run that through and have
it turn that into the the character
animation and um
yeah I just you know it's kind of funny
with with the videos that we've done uh
with stable diffusion it's like we do
this experiment phase and then we go
into making the video and we kind of go
in our like trench and we don't you know
we're not don't update anything yeah we
don't update anything and then like
literally last Friday we're kind of
coming to the clearing and I like pop my
head up and there was this brand new
thing that would have like that is going
to change everything about it because it
basically takes everything we've done
it's not like it replaces everything
we've done it takes everything we've
done and adds another
layer on it and she's amazing multiple
layers I love that didn't invalidate
like four months of work for us yeah no
it doesn't make those shots look extra
cool yeah because once Dean was doing
last Saturday yeah it's uh it's just
it's crazy that like what is that thing
it's called control net and it's
basically just a neural net it's a it's
like a digital net it's a digital net
that like it's you know you there's a
lot of it yeah you control things with
it with um using either Edge detection
or depth maps or really it's just more
like the the challenge of creating
temporal consistency has been like how
do you control the noise how do you
control the decoding process of these
images to uh have it be exactly what you
want while giving it enough freedom to
interpret uh animation or a character or
a different style and so this is just
another way to
take the original image and be like I
want it you know I want it to be like
that image in these ways and it just
gives you more uh control and like I'm
excited to explore that stuff but
yeah it's just it's just funny how we
like
it's kind of the Temptation with this AI
stuff is to just try to keep up really
like try to stay abreast of all of the
uh the new stuff coming out but you do
have to stop at a certain point and be
like we're gonna make something yeah and
that's you know what we did with this
video was like we stopped and we're like
wherever it's at right now we're making
the thing it's good enough go on a side
quest come back to the main story keep
going yeah it's like is it working yeah
I think it is like is it really let's do
some shots okay it's working
so we don't need to change anything to
get it done it's like technically no
could get better though it's like but
it's working it's working all right
freeze everything let's make this yeah
yeah yeah and it's like all the tools
may change but I think
um I think what you've done a great job
of Nico is like kind of educating us all
on how the the technology behind the
stuff is working so we have like a
systems understanding of diffusion
models so it's like whatever tools come
out we know
you know we we can have basically
hypothesis about like how can we get
more consistency and if a new tool comes
out we're like oh it helps it in this
way yeah it's not like you know it's not
like we just have watched a tutorial and
like okay I put the setting on point six
they said check these three boxes yeah
check these three boxes which some of
the stuff is kind of like that yeah
that's true there's uh yeah I definitely
have a screen grab of our specifically
I have that in my prompts thing it's
like here's just a screenshot in case I
forget yeah in case I didn't check the
right box yeah yeah in case I'm not
Sigma enough I can't forget the sigma
box who knows what the adjustment I'm
glad they put it there though because
without that Sigma adjustment once again
who knows what that does yeah none of
this other words
well it's not just checked all the time
who knows it's just one of those little
tests like this is the one checkbox that
makes it work but we're gonna leave at
the very bottom unchecked very bad
because only if you're worthy
unchecked you get a beta adjustment yeah
yeah well it's just like you know it's
like a professor writing a syllabus
they're like this is a very powerful
tool but you have to scroll all the way
to the bottom you have to read every
menu every slider every checkbox yeah
and there's the professors that have
like and this is the one test that
actually counts towards your grade if
you come in and do it you pass this is
my test for you reading my syllabus yeah
there's like the one student that does
it and gets the a yeah yeah yeah because
without that checkbox literally nothing
worked even though all the settings were
the same everything looked like crap and
then you checked that off and it was
like oh we can make this video now yeah
seriously looks like yeah it looked like
actual true crap
okay so you have a you have a computer
program that can just take a video file
and trace it to look like a cartoon and
to a consistently enough every frame
that they're consistent enough that it
doesn't flicker all over the place and
you have an anime cool what about
everything else
how do you make an anime so you can
trace your video but cool but how do you
still make an anime beyond that
I feel like Sam Sam's the man yeah Sam's
the man on that one bill Sami special we
had all started to composite shots and
we were like oh this looks kind of cool
you know you move the background left
you've moved the character right that
looks kind of cool and then walk over
Sam's computer and he's like here's God
Ray's coming down there's a bull a
chalice with fake 3D moves yeah I don't
know I mean that was that's just like
that was a little trial and error there
like the first shot I did was the that
reflection shot and I was like all right
I'm doing this shot because this is like
I I don't know how this is gonna work
and it's gonna be really hard so it's I
think a great stepping stone because
everything else you're like oh yeah
maybe you move the background a little
bit do some light rays whatever it might
even be worth rewinding all the way to
Onset when we're like staying there in
costume we're like What do we do for
this now yeah so I mean how do you make
an anime video you have to write an
anime script that's super dramatic
brother it has lots of like super
intense lines that are really funny to
yell
um so we did that first and then you
film it then well you did voice we did
the voices first which I really liked
actually it made the acting a lot easier
to just make decent enough if not good
well it saves you the problem of like
refining like like
I I like I I like making shorts and
films and stuff like that but I really
hate talking to an actor
like when specifically where you're like
they do a performance and you're like
that was like a it was like a B plus for
what we need here yeah so I'm like can
you like you know it's like really
leaning in there and you're like how do
we figure this out like how do we make
this like even better and like I just I
really hate that nitpicking process of
doing like a directing I do too actually
that part's tough when you're like we
have to here on the moment on set like
refine the performance and even if like
they gave a good performance but it's
just like
you know you see it for the first time
like ah
yeah that's not working actually like no
fault of their own even like they just
don't know where they played yeah and
now it's like okay now we need to
Workshop this right here right now and
how do I get you to do better without
making you feel like you're doing bad
yeah right it's it's really it's really
stressful
um but yeah so you're recording the
lines in advance helps that a lot and
also but also like dude this is like so
much easier when it's an anime style
like everyone gets it instantly you're
like okay we're in the vibe you know and
so from there on it's just like look is
this like a big line is this a small
line like that those are the two yeah
yeah am I Whispering or am I screaming
but you know so but he kicks it off with
like a common understanding
um but then fast forwarding so we're
filming this shot okay so you're like
all right you Nico wrote a shot he wrote
a line in the script that says
you know like uh we're brothers uh like
like we think we're different but on the
C bit of instinct where uh sunlight like
like we were like raise a sunlight
something
yeah there's a mouthful we are the same
Dean wasn't able to just like say yeah
I mean everyone knows that like the
better the script the harder it is to
say the words yeah like you know the
best scripts are very like most actors
can't read the best scripts
and practicing remembering them
but like yeah I'm just saying oh you so
you managed to pull off the line and
we're just filming it and I was like
well it's a shot about two brothers
being the same so let's do something
silly where we're like we've seen this
in other films you see a reflection of
one thing and you pan up but it's now
something else like classic
shot right is that a classic shot it's a
classic shot well it's like can I pause
you say it's silly you say it's silly
but it tells the story and it is it's
ridiculous it's goofy but like we were
talking about this like a lot of
Hollywood movies it's just set up
freaking three camera angles and capture
people talking and that's not a movie
and like that you're making a movie yeah
so I mean man I I want to go off on
another tangent really bad right now do
it so like we were talking about this
this morning
so we're talking about like just this
idea of exploring other anime Concepts
mostly because we're just we're so hyped
on on this stuff right now we want to do
more and we want to do more yeah and and
Clara digital.com
great place to be
so I
compared to the other anime videos that
we've done this is I think the least
funny one in a from a like a
what like intentionally humorous yeah
it's like there's not like jokes in it
yeah with the other videos they have we
got jokes in there so to speak you know
fidget Spinners has jokes in it like the
fingers yeah
it's pretty I mean or like but he's
pretty good that's the thing though oh
yeah are those jokes that's just cool
see because it's like they're not yeah
see actually there are some jokes in
fidget Spinners but I don't think it's
like fingers getting cut off it's like
it's the spilling the fries while
driving yeah it's like spilling the
french fries while driving or 100.
or like those little things there's like
a lot more of those jokes and then like
with this particular script and stuff is
you know it's kind of serious like the
only goofy thing about it is that
they're playing rock paper scissors yeah
and they're taking it whereas if you
just said you're holding two swords and
you're doing a duel and everything else
is the same and the dialogues it's like
it's kind of just a serious anime scene
and
um
I forget where I'm going with this but
it was that idea of okay
like we're not we we think it's like oh
it would be funny to do this shot but
what you're saying is okay let's just
make the most over the top way to show
this moment yeah yeah and like
it's like let me tell the story so
expressly through the I mean it still
takes cleverness to come up with those
visuals but it's like this is the most
like
like clearly bold line version of the
shot yeah well so it's a maximalist
interpretation maximalist interpretation
yeah so so like where I was getting it
with that is that so these things seem
over the top and ridiculous and like
maybe at first someone watched like my
experience watching this is is like okay
this is ridiculous this is over the top
but then suddenly like it holds that
energy so hard that now what you used to
think was ridiculous or potentially too
over the top now it just becomes super
intense yeah because now you're like
okay that is the style of Storytelling
it's like you know it's like RR for
example yeah you didn't really get quote
this morning it's like it starts off
funny because they're taking themselves
so seriously and then eventually the
funding goes away and you're just taking
it seriously with them yeah you're in it
at the end like it's awesome right and
so it's so it's the weirdest effect it's
disarming it's like it's a way to get to
he's like I'm Gonna Make You Care by
making you think you're just ironically
enjoying this yeah
yeah exactly exactly so I I it's just
really interesting it's really cool and
thinking about like how that works with
other animes too and like other shows
I've seen where it's like oh wow that's
so funny and over the top like we're you
know when we watch those other anime
clips and stuff and thought about like
other storytelling Styles yeah it seems
kind of ridiculous Until you realize
like oh wait a second all those inner
monologue battles in Death Note that you
that are kind of over the top and
ridiculous it's like oh wait no that's
actually gripping yeah yeah it turns out
I'm very invested in with this yeah you
are incredible yeah the laughter turns
into investment I think like the cue and
I think that's part of why RR was so
successful in the US is like people I
find myself I'm so tired of cynicism and
self-awareness in the media that I watch
and like we talk about this all the time
like the Marvel movies it's like you you
don't let me enjoy it because you go
there's a clip we go oh this is dumb you
say like the the guy holding bow and
arrows like why am I holding a bow and
arrow this is stupid and I'm like well
then I feel stupid for getting invested
when I watch this kind of stuff where
it's like we are going
Full Tilt and telling the story at the
like 11 volume yeah then you once you
like align with it which I feel like RR
for people watched it there's the scene
uh like 40 minutes in where they set up
this thing where he's swinging off a
bridge with a flag yeah dude and there's
kids on a on a raft and Preposterous
it's so ridiculous because you're like
how do they know to do this and then
there's just a moment where he has used
a wet flag to protect himself from the
flames and he emerges from the flames
and you're like yes
and then and then after they're done
they're walking on the bottom yeah of
the ocean of the ocean and the seats are
going they grab hands like from freaking
uh Predator yeah and you're in yeah
imagine cuts through the Montage then a
song where they're literally like we
where the lyrics are literally telling
you the story and you're you're so in
yeah it's ridiculous but you're like I I
think it's not it flips from like humor
to Delight you know and that's why
you're laughing is you're like I I feel
so joyful right now from like just the
pure commitment to like I think having
fun yeah I think when we were watching
RR in the theater when we did like a
bunch of us from quarter went it was
like at the start you're laughing at it
when he's like yeah flexing on the tiger
and stuff yeah and then at that point
you're laughing with it you're like oh
it it knows what it is and it's just
awesome and then not just not two hits
and then you're just and then I'm just
like this is the greatest movie of all
time yeah it's like it's like this isn't
funny
oh my God the best this is so sick he's
standing up for his bro and like they're
they're yeah like
yeah this is a very pop this is a
positive relationship people need to
take note and this is an example yeah
you know yeah he's gonna lose the dance
battle for his homie yeah yeah so
anyways that it's like it's a it's a
weird concept and yeah RR is like at the
perfect like Touchstone as far as like
finding like how that works it's it's
interesting so bring It full circle like
even more Fuller Circle well when we're
shooting this piece now back to like
this reflection shot it's like we didn't
just shoot random anime shots like we
still like especially you Sam since you
were basically the cinematographer for
all this and coming up with a bunch of
these shots like every shot still had to
tell the story and be a constructed real
animation shot one that's compelling
yeah one that you know emotes and tells
you what the character's feeling so yeah
you had this reflection shot the
reflection shot yeah that's cool I mean
it's just that was the hard one for the
kick things off um well then like the
question is you know we have all these
character shots but like how do you do
the anime shots how do you do you know
like flying around the person let me
finish this reflection shot I think
we've brought it like three times the
whole that whole thing is actually
pretty simple it's basically just
it's the the concept of that shot is
going oh wait a second
doing an impossible camera move that you
can't do for real but as you're watching
it in this 2D version seems like it
works because basically I had this
reflection element uh of Nico and then I
have this like ring of this like maybe
it's like some water bowl
it's never set up whatever it's not in
any other shot but we pan up and we see
Dean and I was like okay that's cool but
like
is this like a are we pulling the camera
back are we just like tilting up like
how's that working and the shot was
actually like kind of janky for most of
it until I realized wait a second like
if I just like force the other front
part of the bowl just like just slide it
up like nothing these are just two
separate pictures just I had like yeah
like two two separate pictures and I I
just slid that up and suddenly the whole
shot like clicked and was like whoa this
felt like a like a 3D camera move even
though in real life it's basically
impossible to film a shot like that from
those angles yeah there's no 3D
whatsoever it's all just planes two
dimensional planes moving around yeah
exactly which is kind of the rule for
the almost all of this that was no 3D
that was the big Epiphany because like
we know about like Parallax you slide an
image left and slide an image right and
it feels like you know you're orbiting
or something's moving but you know going
that level deeper of all right how do
you like really do that how do you take
like three or four layers and with
scaling and zooming kind of get that
effect
um that was so that was like my personal
Epiphany which was a great way to kick
off the piece
but yeah I mean I don't know I could
talk about the other ones a little bit
but they're they're not that as they're
not as dense well but yeah I think I
mean two things would be really cool to
touch upon I think is how to get like
the crazy camera motion of like an anime
shot but also like maybe let's pause
that for a second you know fan are you
comped a bunch of shots and you're like
you did the the crazy you know shoot
Shockwave bit you know at the end where
it's all black and white like what did
you you know coming from an effects
background of comping what did you find
you needed to do when like building an
anime shot once you had like you know a
character shot and you have okay cool
background render what how do you make
it an anime I mean the biggest thing was
just taking inspiration from Sam's stuff
of just being like okay let's go over
the top with this and like we had just
watched a bunch of we basically just all
came in the podcast room here and
watched like my hero Academia and like
top 10 best anime explosions and watch
some like one punch man yeah one punch
man and like we were just like okay we
just have to do that where it's like
style frames where you're like it's
gonna cut away to Black and then it's
going to be black and white and then
you're just gonna see a random camera
flash and then there's going to be a
balloon looking explosion and so it was
just like
treating it frame to frame like as if
you're like I need to draw the like core
of this explosion rather than being like
okay I need to add an explosion element
in here so it was like
all those big impact moments it was like
taking
very very intentional frames not just
like cool I'll just let this element
play out it's like okay the element
plays for two frames and then there's
four new elements in the shot and then
you switch the whole color on everything
and that was it was cool and it was my
first time like really comping infusion
which was definitely challenging at
first but it's it's a great program and
like that was a really I had to
challenge myself to that because I kept
wanting to be like I have to go back to
Nuke but I really like the idea that we
can basically be like every part of this
video was done with free software which
was really cool yeah it's like actually
like a big c story to all this so we we
basically worked in a new compositing
program for like 70 of the shots yeah
and it made it doable because just like
like Fusion being able to utilize GPU so
much better than nuke it made it
actually doable otherwise you're just
like especially the D flicker stuff gets
so heavy and like Dean and I were able
to do it on the spider-verse video
because it was like
it was less shots and we were able to be
like okay sweet we're just gonna
pre-comp these then we don't have to
deal with running D flickers live but
then it ends up getting so heavy so it's
so nice like with Fusion just like you
basically just stack six the flicker
nodes and it's like cool I can just play
back and the factory is all in one it
was we had one resolve project with all
of these comps in there which I at the
beginning of the process was like
there's no way this is going to work
well it wasn't working either yeah then
once we figured out like Nico had it's
like okay everything has its own
timeline for each individual is a
timeline yeah
it's working and that was awesome it
works really well and I feel like we
could do it on a lot more stuff yeah
yeah and the project only like
corrupted a few times
literally to fix it you just go back
into the project browser and just do
copy paste re-update the name and take
the old one throw it in the old bin and
you just keep going is that even the
project corrupting it's just the nature
of like because we're all you know for
people who use the resolve there's like
a collaborative feature which is also
just you know when we're working on Crew
videos it's just huge man is it's one of
the most amazing features like the to be
able to literally be editing
like we've had videos that are it's like
a Friday and we're trying to get the
video done we've had like three editors
working at the same time on a video in
the same project it's so critical it's
the coolest thing in the world like I
feel like
this was the most futuristic video I've
ever been
yeah like it's so cool to yeah to see it
all work there's so many there's so many
things that came together for this video
right it's like not just the AI thing
like there's the whole collaborative
project thing there's the whole like all
the effects comps are stored in the
project and your timeline has like you
know eight layers because you have all
the things there but it plays back in
real time because you've committed to
everything being GPU decoded and somehow
it's working and like you know and you
have the whole diffusion process you
have this whole green screen or costumes
downstairs just ready built and ready to
go with like you know whole like
production crew right and make it happen
anytime you need it so you can get
shoots you can get reshoots because it's
all experimental right it's like you
don't know you make it two hours done
you might shoot the whole day and none
of it works and you go back and shoot
new shots maybe you don't need to shoot
new shots it's like you can't commit to
any of it and you just have to be like
ready to go at a moment's notice of
course you have the whole diffusion
process that we did on top of it all the
comping and then the whole like everyone
gets to like do anime oh yeah learn
anime because I mean it was cool seeing
how it was that ramp of all right what's
going on like how how do we find the
vibe here to announce suddenly
everyone's just doing expert level anime
shots yeah better I keep thinking back
to like that very first shot of like
Dean walking sideways yeah like that
shot and then like the delayer shots
that you're doing now like it's the
fistline I didn't even know that was
done I was just watching and it happened
I was like
this is it was the coolest shot that
first walking shot was just like I hate
fusion and then by the end I'm like this
is sick this is great dude the character
Arc yeah yeah no it was awesome
it's a yeah it was so cool like you were
saying Nico it's so awesome like just
with even since I've been at Corridor
just seeing the build out of like having
the green screen psych and now the trust
it's like oh we gotta shoot on the green
screen walk down hit a button on an iPad
full lighting setup filming on a phone
for most of them yeah yeah
take it to Anime movies for a second
here so okay every anime has the crazy
anime moves the camera orbits the
character and they're all distorted and
how are we gonna do this as we like look
at our giant jib arm with the red on it
it's like hmm and Sam's like
put this iPhone on a gimbal yeah and
then I started just wanting using it
more casually like all the king stuff at
the end yeah because it works so well
like at the end I literally came down
here with the iPhone and I just like put
it on the selfie camera
filming solo because I was just like oh
that's some fun that's framing's fine I
do it like I don't need to worry if it's
in Focus or anything I don't think
anybody yeah no I literally walked
downstairs and I just stopped on the
stairs and Sam's like in full costume
with this freaking white beard and big
eyebrows and he just looks up at me and
just like it goes back to what he's
doing on the phone when I step back and
I look and yeah in my other hand I'm
holding my up my phone with like I just
used voice memo to record the timeline
and I just like I'm playing it back down
near my waist and then like mining the
words and then I watched the final shot
right now I'm like that looks like a
shot from an animated film like not to
mention those were then processed with
like the best like with the control net
in there like if they're Peak
it's like yeah the last shots we've done
so they're like the Pinnacle of our
process that we
like the filming process is like
literally the jankiest well and that's
what I wanted to mention is like you
were talking about how every shot is
going through four programs and it's
like you know there's all this stuff
being done to every single shot but it's
like on the front end it each of those
steps compresses down what we really
have to do on the shooting side which is
like again we got to the point where
we're just like I grab the iPhone
12 mini the camera at something and
you're like make it look good yeah which
is crazy because it really means that in
the future you can kind of just use any
camera as long as it's good enough yeah
it's like is it a person I think so
where are the eyes around there cool we
got it from here yeah we know what you
want I mean that's that's kind of the
coolest thing about this video is like
anyone could shoot it on their phone
stable diffusion's free well uh
automatic one one it's free one one one
one automatic eleven eleven eleven yeah
and DaVinci Resolve and fusion is free
it's like there's no excuses
the thing is he can literally build your
costumes out of cardboard because once
you put the filter on it it looks good
like Sam's King costume in real life is
the cheapest Halloween beer
eyebrows and yeah potato sack with a
rope a random beer a beard wasn't even
sticking to my face and I found all the
stuff in the outro and I look at the
footage and the Beard's like mirror like
people wobbling around and stuff and I'm
like I was like oh God I don't want to
reshoot this but then we process it all
it's like oh perfect it looks great yeah
it's like we literally like we started
like we started shooting everything
initially with like nice lighting
because I thought we should light it
nicely so it looks nice later by the end
like another nice lighting looked that
great turns out all you need is one
light harsh not doesn't mean sashes one
harsh white from the side that's all you
want because that actually looks the
best it's like you literally you light
it poorly shoot it on a phone janky
costumes like Dean's costume is
literally a bunch of tape yeah around
his collar and his chest it's like let's
get a good costume and then like it's
like oh anime looks a little more simple
you're wearing one of your costumes
the final shot you're wearing this
hoodie yeah yeah the hoodie I'm wearing
right now is in one of the shirts oh man
yeah we should treat ourselves what's
what you're wearing for the the Friday
to the watches let's play The Green
Screen version for everyone yeah I do I
do really want to like I think it's the
date of the day of this podcast by the
way the green screen versus oh tomorrow
the green screen versus I do want to
like do a version just a quick quick key
on all the shots so we have the same
backgrounds but it's us for real I do
have a lot of them keyed already yeah
actually they we look like such dorks oh
my God and uh yeah we're working I'm
gonna edit and like it was halfway done
and you like you'd watch a sequence of
shots especially like if Sam like had a
stretch of shots that he had done God
damn this is sick and then pop to one of
us in real life going like you know not
what you do oh my god
well I'm just I'm trying to convey
through audio the visual effects
yeah wait but there's one piece where
we're missing that did cost a little bit
of money and it was Sam's unreal
environment
unreal
always living in the background man they
never get the foreground light but I
have to admit I I was kind of a big
spender I also spent an additional
thirty dollars on a cell shading plug-in
for unreal oh wow oh really and I used
it on just one shot which was this shot
where it's zooming up the castle behind
you oh is that a 3D shot yeah I did put
one 3D model in the video it's in there
for just a moment though one 3D render
um and then the Cathedral at the end
that blows up that's uh one of the kit
bash 3D uh Gothic Cathedral things that
I put together and then ran that through
stable yeah so yeah that's what's that
part of it is very exciting to me we you
know we like another revolutionary thing
under the hood that's just quiet yeah we
stayed away from the there's I guess one
3D shot but we tried to stay away from
the 3D camera moves but
that's where I feel like because you
know Sam and Nico you guys have been
having these parallel Journeys with
learning these Tech you know yeah yeah
Sam's been an unreal Nico's been doing
the AI stuff and this was the first
video where it came together yeah
and I feel like there's very exciting
very exciting possibilities there as
well it's like okay you have all these
characters but I need a background the
thing is the background needs to be like
an actual like consistent space it can't
just be you can't just go like
mid-journing type Cathedral about you
know wall yeah you can get freaking so
much randomly got way better at the end
too super consistent yeah it was looking
really super sharp that's what Dean was
like oh that's a check box you're going
to want to hit right there like oh and I
check it and my computer doesn't crash
anymore and it makes better
yeah it's a sandwich just like you go
through the edit and look at a shot be
like I imagine the background would be
looking at this and then you go to the
Google engine move the camera roughly
there
grab a screen grab just from literally
from the video from the viewport no not
on Windows there's a screenshot feature
in unreal that like just snaps to
slightly better settings briefly and
takes a screenshot so you know it
renders in like a millisecond goes to
another folder drags into stable
diffusion applies just a nice light like
painting layer just like a little bit of
oil painting please you know I'm
simplifying this the prompts are a
little more nuanced I think it's
something like 90s anime 90s anime Pages
expressive expressive oil painting oil
painting sometimes Sam writes Cathedral
interior sometimes you have to remind it
you're like you don't realize what
you're looking at those are stained
glass windows
that's a white marble Angelic statue
those are candles Oh you mean like this
oh my bad sorry yeah
so that's what's the same thing you guys
do on the images too you're just like
yeah but then we skipped the whole like
you know
[Laughter]
I don't have lazy eyes yeah
but you know the background is it's
always just a picture we're never doing
video for the background it's always
just a picture so you just take that one
you know image damage picture I'll
disable the fusion from unreal and Boop
off it goes so fun it's so fun it's so
fun hey what are your favorite negative
prompts to use in this
I didn't do a lot honestly I just did
like Blurry and compression that was it
lazy-eyed that was the new one cataracts
yeah
you're sick that you sit down with
stable Fusion you're like listen he's
not deformed yeah that's okay oh he's
farmed he's formed oh I have a question
uh for you speaking about weird words
um
uh uh what is what is that word oh my
gosh not subtlety or whatever maximalism
no no there's a word that people
subliminal subliminal so so what does
subliminal mean in relationship to
liminal
I'm curious oh yeah because it's
subliminal
and then there's liminal is it liminal
like aware of it and subliminal is like
a low content this whole liminal spaces
thing because like right now that seems
more like a subliminal space
[Laughter]
you're right it should be subliminal
throw that in your negative prompts
subliminals
I want this right on the liminal
yeah sorry anyways I did find that a lot
of times you'd have to prompt talking as
a positive problem to allow it to like
draw an open mouth but not always if
it's closed it knew it could draw a
closed mouth too I like fingernails
that's a great negative problem oh yeah
because it's also a good positive
problem it depends on if you're saying
the back or the front of the hands
yeah there's monster that's another one
classic and also you negative prompted
detailed and intricate so and those are
those are absolutely critical putting in
like detailed photographs CGI render
like all the things that you know
because it's gonna because it has our
likeness it's gonna lean towards making
like a realistic person and it's crazy
because I was just using it I was using
those negative prompts on just like a
random generation and that is really I
mean that almost is more important than
most of the sliders we're using is like
just don't make it real yeah and then
it's like oh just make it a cartoon I
found the cell shading positive prompt
was the one that hit it the most of
being like cool it's not like Photo real
so for me to sell animation yeah very
similar yeah yeah 1l not two L's one L
one L cell animation yeah yeah the
reminder I don't want a photo please I
know it looks like a photo I want to
give it to you I want to look like a
cartoon please oh sorry yeah
I'm very curious because I think there
will be a little bit of backlash
AI art yeah you know controversy going
on yeah
CG mode oh well he made the video I mean
this is like I think the best case for
AI art yeah that you can currently make
at the moment sorry like I really really
lofty speech here uh you know I'm just
saying of anyone who's attempted to ever
make air before
this certainly presents the best
positive use case for AI art and
um yeah I think people should
I I mean even if you like hate AI art
maybe I think there's maybe a little bit
of understanding or like you know
there's like a little bit you can take
away from this yeah um it goes oh
wow a brighter future yeah I hope people
realize how much like actual time was
put into every frame it wasn't just the
button of make anime it was like okay
like you said there's eight steps just
to get to the point where we're now
actually going in and actually animating
making the keyframes like well and I
think importantly like it's not like
we're an animation studio and we're like
cool we can just get rid of some
people's jobs this was like oh we have
an obviously you've always wanted to do
something new yeah yeah we've made anime
videos multiple times before but we've
never got to do the cartoon thing yeah
because it's just not something we were
capable of doing
yeah yeah
well a little bit of a hot take but I
honestly think that all images in the
stability model and uh what a lie Leon
Leon yeah that should be considered like
you know for use I think it's just like
I think there's a Nuance where it's like
if you've trained a model on public data
I feel like the model should be
available to the public yeah I think
that's really what it comes down to at
this point yeah it's like yeah because
you look at Dolly and stuff like that
and like if you think about these models
if you were to make this hyper corporate
super light hyper licensed model it's
like what are you gonna be able to do
with it you know you're not gonna be
able to do that much and it kind of
requires like for all these things like
once again
where are all the crying journalists you
know uh talking about GPT you know three
three yeah well and two yeah and all the
other ones like anyone who's ever
written all these novelists I'm sure
they were there yeah I'm sure but I
guess of the internet you know I just
didn't blow in that direction at the
time the internet horns weren't loud
enough back then
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you hear that
they're getting angry
they're coming I mean brace yourselves
walk this comment section down quickly
I mean at least I like I I get I get the
concerns by like copying art because
look at the end of the day it's like
copying art has been something that's
been easy to do for a long time too it's
kind of like deep fix it's like it's
been easy to do you can copy [__] it's
easy you can rip people off it's easy
but thank goodness like we as a people
don't think it's cool and people do that
let me call them out for it because when
it comes to like these AI tools yeah
sure it makes it easier to like copy
people's style so somebody just rips out
somebody's style call them out and be
like you rip that person off screw you
like people still should create their
own Styles and do their own things with
this
you know but like these tools themselves
are amazing like they're so liberating
like
here actual artists here in this room
use these tools and let me tell you
they're awesome and like there's so many
cool things you can do with it it's just
we as also consumers of art need to make
sure we're holding ourselves to a
standard of consumption that we don't
let people get away with ripping other
people off and keeping it open source
like you said and keeping it open source
because yeah if if they close down these
these models but it has copyrighted data
in it that's when it starts to get like
hey who are you to yeah take all these
images but if it's for the people you
know if you're from the people for the
people yeah by the people and then it's
like and then it only because if it's
open source then it only becomes about
what is the final product and is that
copyright or is that like
have you stolen that from somebody yeah
and if you know then it's just a simple
yes or no because you can just easily
compare it to the original yeah yeah
it's interesting stuff interesting times
like just think about how fast things
are changing like
I know that's a fear a lot of people are
kind of starting to like have it's like
how fast things are changing
you know how much easier is it getting
to do all this kind of stuff but it's
like we're still people making it for
people these programs aren't just doing
it in and of themselves like this is
still like somebody doing it with the
end goal of
entertaining somebody else or
communicating with someone else like
so I don't know like
it's gonna be interesting but it's not
all bad it's not all good
but also like you have to make an anime
this whole video this whole video is
really still an example of how much work
is still required yeah like it's like
even if I could be like hey copy this
guy's art style with one button like it
doesn't solve the problem of having to
write a video and film the whole thing
and edit the piece and do the sound of
the music and then composite the shots
and get everything moving right and make
it feel like it's like there's still
tons of artistry and time you know and
no matter what the name on my desk says
what I'm called you know CGI animator AI
guy you know whatever it's like it's
still a person creating art and doing it
with quite a quite a bit of originality
put into it even if there's other
Inspirations going into it like it
doesn't take away from the fact that we
all still had to go through that whole
process together here and do the work
yeah I find myself thinking about books
a lot like
it's very easy these days to get a book
printed like incredibly easy it's
basically free right anybody can get a
book printed but writing a book an
actual book that people value and care
about is hard because it's the ideas and
the thoughts and like the experiences
and wisdom and everything and the craft
that you bring as an author that we
value even though like you can go boop
boop on a keyboard and anybody can do
that like you can actually anybody can
physically create it thank God open
source yeah
but I think there's a I think there's
gonna be an aspect of like visual art
that's going to reach that like movies
video even pictures like that's been
locked off to people you know pictures
got democratized at the camera
you know movies are got democratized
with digital video it wasn't until
recently right it was very recent and
like visual effects aren't really
democratized you know they're kind of
getting there but at a certain point
it's gonna be like writing it's gonna be
as easy as writing you can I can write
the man set his chair down on the moon
which was plated with gold and it didn't
cost me anything to bring that that
image to your mind if I want to do that
in video form it's very hard but very
soon not not very soon not next week but
soonish it's not going to be that hard
to do that and that can be scary but at
the same time it doesn't make art
irrelevant doesn't make visuals relevant
like we still value authors you know
anybody can write but we still value
good authors
so I don't know and in fact there's more
authors now than ever before
so yeah
I hope it works out if not you know
we'll make some cool anime videos before
everything explodes but you know might
as well
we'll do what we can I'm down sweet I'll
throw some anime in my lines on a thing
yeah I'll slap anime lines on anything
so yeah to everybody out there who's
like sharing their knowledge and pushing
it forwards awesome thank you so much I
hope we've contributed a little bit to
that and we can help push knowledge
forwards as well
yeah
yeah in the meantime if you want to make
a video like this what are you waiting
for everything's free
everything's just free I feel like be
like saying it was a little complicated
all right it's very small sales pitch
here we go I have a Click by click
tutorial on Corridor digital.com I'm
pushing quarter digital so hard right
now because it's that the website the
subscribers on the website is really
what enabled us to make this project
because it's like you can't support
these things with ads you can't support
them with brand Integrations right they
need to be made for the people who want
it and he made for the audience and so
the direct support of an audience
directly to us is what makes it happen
so yeah there's a whole tutorial Click
by click on quarter digital of course a
whole bunch of other stuff so yeah if
you like our stuff and you want to see
us make more of these anime videos it
would really mean a lot to us if you
supported us there
also sweet limited edition merch drop
the show yeah oh yeah that's right okay
we should mention this too hey so hey
baby maybe so we can go get a shirt real
quick
listening to it okay whatever uh you can
go to our insta you can see it on
anything else but yeah yeah Kendra Toms
designed all our other anime shirts she
made a cool new one for this video and
it's on sale limited edition yeah
because it means if you we're not making
them unless you order them you know
there's not going to be like a stock
left around at the end of the week you
have to order one if you want one so if
you're a subscriber on a website guess
what you get 15 off and if you're not a
subscriber it's worth subscribing to the
website and then using your discount
code as a member because then it's the
same price and basically you get a free
month of subscription on the website so
there you go
approach it there you have it pro tip
and then you get to watch the tutorial
inside of a dungeon okay and all the
other shows crew cuts everything
extended extended reacts natural
filmmaking oh
and also am I blowing it I'm gonna
mention it secretly but also Smart TV is
kind of happening it's actually already
out on some systems maybe but I'm not
gonna say anything else yeah Smart TVs
we were kind of waiting until it's like
TV smart hit all of them and like really
make an announcement but yeah it's only
only true towns out here listening to
the podcast this late in the game yeah
but yeah Smart TV's happening very
shortly too if not I mean it already is
happening it's already on like half the
platforms and it's out for like
certification on the other ones right
now sweet but we'll do like pretend you
didn't hear that we're gonna because
we'll actually celebrate like a grand
opening like next podcast yeah
oh man it's been a lot of work making
this video
this is going to be nice to uh I'm so
excited for people to see it me too I
hope we launched it just right just
right just right it's gonna be just
right
yep okay all right until next time guys
scream peace
okay I'm just gonna go
[Music]
[Applause]
good
subtle